Good, a kidney stone occurrence after my last blood work be the cause of higher PSA and stubborn
inflammation and other bad blood, blood work markers. So if you had, if you didn't have any
peed from, let's say you didn't have any pain, no issues, no knowledge of a kidney stone and then you
go get your blood tested and then you find out afterwards. So you go get your blood drawn,
then you find out three days later that you have a kidney stone and you have all sorts of
symptoms because of that, then I would say no. But if you were in the middle of a kidney stone
passing and it was a lot of pain, that would cause a lot of inflammation and yes, that could throw
off your blood work, it could even throw off your PSA. But if you weren't having those symptoms
at the time of the blood draw, then I would say probably not because a kidney stone that isn't
giving you symptoms is not going to really do really a disruption. The fact that the kidney stone is
in the kidneys, let's say it's not causing any issues, could a kidney stone or the kidney's cause
abnormal blood markers? Maybe with kidney markers, maybe your BUN. Yes, but as far as
elevating the PSA, I doubt that. If you again, if you were the throws of passing a kidney stone
with an enormous amount of pain, that could throw off a lot of things because inflammation is going to be
so high. But you probably wouldn't have a lot of, you might have difficulty and blood markers show
you'd stress out the kidney if you had an asymptomatic kidney stone. But it probably would not be
raised any other markers other than just kidney markers if it was an asymptomatic. If you were at
a asymptomatic stage, hopefully that helps out a lot.